President Trump is claiming vindication
after the Supreme Court allowed his
travel ban to stay in place
the courts conservative majority voted
to uphold the ban that affects seven
countries five of them are majority
Muslim nations the five to four ruling
declared presidents have broad authority
to make national security judgments over
immigration after the ruling the
president tweeted Supreme Court upholds
Trump travel ban Wow
exclamation point Jan Crawford is at the
Supreme Court with the significance of
this decision Jang good morning
well good morning nori you know
vindication because the president had
lost it almost every turn in the lower
courts and in a statement after the
decision he vowed he would continue
fighting for an immigration system that
he says will serve the interests of
American citizens I will always be
defending the sovereignty the safety and
the security of the American people the
administration framed the decision is a
victory for security this decision is
critical to ensuring the continued
authority of President Trump as the
Supreme Court emphasized presidents have
long had sweeping Authority in defense
of the nation but Democrats were quick
to call the ban discrimination that
hurts the country it is dangerous it
makes us less sane Chief Justice John
Roberts his opinion said this ban
president's third tried did not target
Muslims and covered five countries that
past administrations had identified as
security risks the policy is a far cry
from the president's first effort that
caused chaos at airports worldwide
Donald J Trump is calling for a total
and complete shutdown of Muslims
entering the United States dissenting
justices said his campaign statement
showed it was motivated by religious
hostility Justice Sonia Sotomayor wrote
a reasonable observer would conclude it
was motivated by anti-muslim animus and
there comes no that we are we have
pretty damn Rami oh man so is a US
citizen whose Yemeni wife and children
are waiting for visas their future and
that of other immigrant families is now
in question we are all equal in this
country and we have rights
it's protected well guess what it's not
now the opinion said it was not
endorsing the soundness of the policy
and Justice Anthony Kennedy wrote a
separate concurring opinion he was in
the majority and without directly naming
president Trump said that government
officials must stay committed to
preserving our constitutional liberties
that an anxious world is watching John
Jan Crawford thanks so much